this is 16 K strands of dragon beards
candy dice
look at that hi today we're gonna try
and make this super cool looking con
candy called dragon beards candy this
candy originated from China apparently
ancient Emperor's used to eat this think
of cotton candy that's made purely from
your hands that's pretty cool
success rate is super super low but
we're still gonna give it a shot let's
do it the ingredients are pretty simple
it's basically just sugar sugar sugar
sugar and water sugar water corn syrup
vinegar maltose just put them all in
this pot boil them up until it becomes a
thick gooey liquid that we're then gonna
shape into candy I also got burn relief
gel because I wasn't sure if I would
burn myself so one step at a time if I
remember correctly what I'm supposed to
do no sugar first get every single bit
altos super gooey that's what it looks
like from the videos and the recipes I
saw I'm supposed to turn this on and
then not stir it if you stir it the
sugar is gonna crystallize and if it
crystallizes you're screwed and that is
a big no-no oh my god okay so now I'm
supposed to just leave it run and I'm
not the most patient person in the world
so
[Music]
it's about 225 looks like a little
volcano you can only look at it which is
what I'm doing looking at it but it's so
slow I think I'm good for sumo that's
277 I don't know if we're screwed
gonna pour this into the silicon mold oh
my god okay oh it was we're gonna let it
cool down for a little bit we are back
in business cornstarch is to keep it
from sticking together here we go I
think it's ready
ooh look at that this is what it looks
like right now very very pliable we're
gonna poke a hole through this cover it
and starch ooh
feels nice we're gonna shape it into a
ring keep doing this and then twisting
it one ring becomes - rings - rings
becomes four rings up until we get
16,000 rings that sounds really
ambitious it is good so far
twist it now we have two rings
we're gonna keep pulling it oh my god in
the trash guess that means are gonna do
another one here we go
nope
[Music]
boy this means we have to come back redo
the sugar alright next time we can cut
I'm so sad after work now I'm just gonna
keep on doing this just can't just give
up my dad didn't bring me up like that
I took the sugar less this time last
time I couldn't even get it this big
he's good
stretchy stretchy mmm two two two four
oh look at that it's stretching there's
no cracks I think of my ashley work
board +4 8 to 16 it definitely feels
very flexible 32 eight like I was just
so much better than the first bash maybe
they just don't want me to succeed in
front of people
32 plus 32 is 64 it looks like it's
going somewhere
128 pulling it 256 looks like it's
working 512 I couldn't even get past two
last time 2048 this is really working my
muscles 4096 8192 so close laughs done
16300
before yo ya 16 care did it here we go
one more 32,768 here it is still get
Dragon's beard haha this looks like a
400 thread count Egyptian cotton
bedsheets now we're gonna fill it with a
peanut filling oh I'm so excited
it looks like whiskers take your hand
put it in here there's a tiny little
bite right there somebody want to try
this I did it I feel like I just climbed
a mountain and I'm at the very top
people who are professionals at this and
what they do really is amazing so that's
another thing off of my bucket list I
made the impossible cotton candy
from ancient China let's see what we can
do next
[Music]